The red pill has been extended to us once
again, and it could mark the beginning of
something major.
In summer 2019, Warner Bros. announced that
a new Matrix movie was in the works, and since
then, people have been wondering whether the
franchise might ultimately extend beyond the
upcoming fourth installment.
Well, according to a recent article in We
Got This Covered, the as-yet-untitled film
will indeed blossom into a second Matrix trilogy.
The article also revealed that,
"[While] Keanu Reeves and Carrie-Anne Moss
are coming back as Neo and Trinity for the
new movie, it’s unclear as of yet if [they'll]
return for the next two as well."
Of course, we should remind you that this
is all just a rumor at this point.
Still, the possibility of a new Matrix trilogy
begs the question: Would it be worth revisiting
the franchise for not just one, but three
more films?
As has been widely reported, Lilly Wachowski,
who co-created the franchise with her sister
Lana, isn't involved in the upcoming installment.
As Decider reported back in August 2019, she
hasn't specifically stated why she's not working
on the fourth Matrix film, but it sounds like
she's not feeling particularly inspired by
the sci-fi genre at the moment.
In fact, she revealed that,
"My agent kept sending me stuff, and a lot
of science fiction.
Great.
It's good stuff, science fiction.
You get to talk a lot about a lot of subjects.
There's always fabulous subtext in science
fiction.
Since my transition, I'm not really interested
in subtext at this time."
As you probably know, Lilly came out as a
transgender woman in 2016, and her sister
Lana did the same back in 2012.
And although Lilly sounds a bit disenchanted
with the sci-fi genre these days, she's reportedly
totally down with the idea of a fourth Matrix
film, even if she's not involved in making
it.
In August 2019, she told Slash Film,
"I like it when stories go out into the world
and then come back to you in different ways.
I mean, that's what storytelling is all about.
I'm part of a bigger thing.
I don't have any ownership over stuff like
that, so whatever story anybody wants to tell,
I can't wait to hear.
I hope [the fourth Matrix is] better than
the original."
Of course, improving on the original Matrix
is a rather tall order.
In fact, one could argue that the first two
sequels didn't exactly rise to the task.
Meanwhile, franchise fatigue is a very real
thing, and it's only getting realer.
As you may recall, people were already growing
weary of the Matrix franchise by the time
The Matrix Revolutions came out.
Just look at the dismal reviews for that film
if you don't believe us.
But after two long decades away from Neo and
his cohorts, fans might be totally pumped
to plug back into The Matrix…but whether
the fourth film is ultimately a worthwhile
chapter in the saga remains to be seen.
The hit-and-miss critical performance of both
the latest Star Wars trilogy and the prequel
trilogy potentially serve as cautionary tales
about what happens when you create new franchise
installments out of thin air.
Sure, a studio stands to make billions of
dollars, but time will tell whether these
latter entries ultimately dampen the legacy
of the original trio of films.
As for the upcoming Matrix movie, Jonathan
Groff, Neil Patrick Harris and Yahya Abdul-Mateen
II have been cast in super-secretive roles…and
it's rumored that Mateen is playing a younger
version of Laurence Fishburne's Morpheus character.
If that's true, perhaps we should all brace
ourselves for some sort of mind-melting, totally
convoluted time-travel plot.
Meanwhile, a new wave of characters does leave
the door open for more entries down the line.
Only time will tell.
Back in September 2019, Keanu Reeves weighed
in on the new Matrix screenplay in an interview
with Entertainment Tonight:
"It's very ambitious.
As it should be."
Here's hoping the fourth Matrix doesn't just
trot out the same ideas as its three predecessors.
After all, the world only needs so many sensual
space raves.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.